hello and welcome to the plane endless
fighter think is playing the Sicilian so
let's go with one year for maybe I'm
wrong it ever interesting open Sicilian
maybe oh this one that it's not exactly
exactly my forte have not yet studied
the rouser which is a bit of an issue
actually if you don't know stuff with
wise this is a very good opening I think
this is this is decent ow
play a little bit in English a textile
you have a tick on f6 this is winning a
bit of material but that probably does
not do all that great Bishop takes them
that's a offered structure which of the
exhibition takes Queen d6s for them I'm
talking about maybe just develop cannot
be bad at least I hope
ok this one happy to take gain some
space
but this cannot be bad for white that
that I really think is quite impossible
v5 yeah so before 92 this is still on
[Music]
night come see em over to possibly go to
f5 maybe Bishop c4 man I maybe should
have taken this opportunity it's not a
bad diagonal you know yeah that I'm
doing this now this is a really good
diagonal lettuce fields dangerous like
if you ask me 96 the way I overlooked
this move just a simple move that I did
not appreciate ok let's take here and
then see what happens
okay I mean if this is good food like
and something is really wrong with Jess
let's see how can i how can I put punish
him here all kinds of things look
possible the first it comes to mind is
night f5 takes and then look aged six it
looks extremely dangerous okay h6 g6
let's have to calculate completely can
you do something else that is simpler
somehow g5 is not hanging
do to them due to this pin but should h6
immediately a rogue age 6 immediately
maybe just try to double it also
threatens 95 okay let's do it i cannot
spend so long now this is certainly
winning for why this position before
Game six it just not I just wasn't sure
how exactly yeah yeah nite f5 is pretty
good I think I'm pretty good at it
should it should kill him actually I
don't I dare they don't think he can
take and if you cannot take the night
yeah here but should be six should win
the house i'm not mistaken my queen is
covered black resigned yeah that was
something went wrong there for black and
i'm not quite sure what exactly so let's
let's have a look em if we join here and
one thing that i should should mention
is that like here yeah black will just
take with the bishop you will not do
this this would be quite risky I think
but he will just take with the bishop
and this kind of situation is pretty
awful because black has a good choice
that I can play in a meek fashion like
this and never be worse with this
fantastic bishops even just taking is
completely okay even though the engine
gives white an advantage but this is not
the point this is even stronger the
suspicion is so fantastically strong
black is happy to give up a pony so and
maybe the timing was off somehow for
black I'm very sure that this should be
ok but maybe before is wrong that it
actually that I get this opportunity
to play Bishop c4 I appreciate the fact
that makes perfect sense and the engine
suggestion preventing this and then
giving about equal am that that makes
sense a lot and TM already thinks are a
bit dangerous yeah after Bishop c4 the
engine is giving a pretty unpretty it
gives it when you have this is too much
the bishop on c4 is just right on that
diagonal and I'm ready to open up the H
file so here I'm still quite curious yes
of course I saw this move but I wasn't
sure if I'm winning we gave six is what
I calculated but I couldn't quite figure
out if that is the winner or not it
looks like it should be wit ya like an
engine is of course just like plus 4y
Wow but I don't think this was
particularly bad now and then it also
means I'm just preparing night at five
Andrew cage one day I didn't really see
a good mood for black and tier 95 is
just straight straight killin you cannot
take care because I just can take it sex
with the bishop begging material and
attacking in the process yeah there
should be six wins wins everything and I
came back white will be a rock up with a
ongoing attack okay thanks for watching